[Ukraїner,
Експедиція]
[Полтава,
Полтавщина]
Про нас в Полтаві дуже багато хто знає,
дуже багато звертаються.
[Марина Цигрик,
виконавча директорка ГО «Еколтава»]
Ми, фактично, зараз єдина
екологічна організація в місті.
І зі всіма проблемами звертаються до нас.
Все починалося з прибирання.
Ми просто бачили сміття і починали його прибирати,
організовувалися з людьми і прибирали відходи.
А потім ми вирішили, що збирати сміття просто,
не логічно і це може тривати вічно.
І зрозуміли, що треба змінювати все
на набагато вищому рівні.
Ми працювали раніше виключно в місті,
а зараз перейшли також на громади.
Тому що бачимо, що в громад є
дуже велике бажання змінюватися.
І, власне, ми допомагаємо громадам
впроваджувати екологічні рішення.
Окрім відходів, ми також займаємося
проблемами зміни клімату,
адаптації до зміни клімату і енергоефективності.
Мені ще здається, що в нас,
в Україні, є дуже багато проблем,
але є дуже-дуже прекрасні можливості для того,
щоб вирішувати ці проблеми.
І ти можеш бачити результати своєї роботи,
або декількох місяців свого життя.
І це дуже тішить, насправді.
Я екологиня.
Так, я, власне, екологиня і я прийшла
волонтерити в організацію,
і почала бачити тут рішення.
Наша команда, яка є в сьогоднішньому складі,
працює вже понад 5 років.
Нам всім боліли проблеми екологічні, проблеми відходів.
Але я думаю, що в кожного була якась
своя внутрішня ціль щось робити.
Скоріш за все, мабуть для себе,
щоб почуватися безпечно
і, я би сказала, щасливо в цьому житті.
Ми однодумці і іноді ми не розуміємо, звідки ми, взагалі,
прийшли і всі разом згрупувалися.
Але так зійшлося.
Насправді, так, ми тут проводимо більшу частину наших днів.
І тому тут такє... В нас трохи домашня іноді буває атмосфера.
Ми ще любимо ввечері запалити гірлянди...
[російською] І працювати.
[сміються усі разом]
[Маргарита Мостова,
координаторка проєктів ГО «Еколтава»]
Насправді, я прийшла в «Еколтаву» через бажання творчості.
Ще коли була студенткою.
Зараз мій профіль — комунікації.
Я за освітою піарниця.
Але для себе вирішила, що моя місія буде такою...
Що я буду старатися для того,
аби в суспільстві з'явилося дуже багато якісних,
ґрунтовних матеріалів про екологічні загрози, проблеми.
Драйвить, що ти не просто живеш і забираєш ресурси.
[Аделіна Захарченко,
менеджерка з логістики ГО «Еколтава»]
А ти можеш допомагати іншим і, зокрема,
собі вписуватись більш гармонійно в цей світ.
І от я тут.
[сміється]
Ну не знаю, що я.
Я навчався в Німеччині, робив дослідження в Німеччині.
І планую закінчити там аспірантуру.
[Максим Макуха,
технічний фахівець ГО «Еколтава»]
Моя тема, якою я дуже цікавлюсь, — це
лісосмуги і стале сільське господарство.
А в принципі, зараз будую, сподіваюсь,
енергопасивний або, навіть, енергоактивний будинок
Зі всякими штуковинами.
Освіта в мене інженерна.
Правда, Максе, де народився, там і знадобився?
Так, де народився, там і знадобився. Точно.
Я почала збирати батарейки в селі в себе.
Я отруїлася парами від батарейок, загалом.
І в мене були проблеми з ногами.
Я не могла нормально ходити якийсь період.
І в мене тоді таке трохи переосмислення сталося в житті.
І я вирішила, що я не хочу
продовжувати жити, як я жила раніше,
Я хочу робити щось суспільно корисне.
Ну і знову ж таки, є багато проблем, які треба вирішувати.
Я пам'ятаю, я вилікувалася, все повернулося до норми.
Я приїхала, ми біля Максового дому саджали дерева.
Засадили пустище і, власне, після цього все почалося.
Ми дуже багато працювали з школами,
просто з бізнесом, просто з людьми.
Пропонували різні рішення владі,
але нас не хотіли чути
Тому ми переходили до таких радикальних мір.
Подавали позов, і вимагали зобов'язувати їх виконувати ті умови,
які ми там прописували, власне, в позовах.
Коли відбувалися ці судові процеси,
в нас трохи змінилася влада.
І в нас змінився очільник міста, власне.
І нам запропонували співпрацю.
І ми почали шукати компроміси.
Почали входити в робочі групи.
І намагаємося, щоб всі всіх почули: ми владу, влада нас.
Люди в селі хочуть бачити зміни.
В селі, взагалі, немає ніяких, я би сказала, нормальних умов для того,
щоб люди могли нормально поводитися з відходами
І дуже бракує інформування.
«Екологічні ініціативи».
Цей проект почався 2 роки тому, спільно з обласною радою.
Власне, це [вказує на екобус, що стоїть позаду]
вже результат нашої співпраці.
Минулого року в 25 громадах було реалізовано
по одному проекту, власне.
Це стосувалося відходів, озеленення,
просвітництва, публічних красивих просторів.
Після того, як ми проводили кілька років
уже ці екологічні ініціативи,
і люди впроваджували в себе ці рішення,
і говорили, що ми хочемо більше, нам це відгукується,
ми хочемо бачити в себе умови для здачі небезпечних відходів,
власне, і почали вже приходити до цієї ідеї.
І цей екобус, він, насправді, є першим в Україні,
що курсує по всій області.
Тут збираються термометри, люмінесцентні лампи і батарейки, звичайно ж.
Екобус приїжджає в громаду.
Про це сповіщається всюди, де тільки можливо:
сільські газети, «Фейсбук» сторінка, радіо.
Люди про це знають, і приходять, здають відходи.
Це є безкоштовним.
Усі відходи обов’язково мають бути запакованими.
Це все здається в різні пункти на утилізацію.
Батарейки будуть їхати спочатку в Київ, на перетримку,
а потім відправляються в Румунію.
А, власне, лампи відправляються власне в Львівську область, в Боднарівку.
Це єдине, поки що, місце, де у нас утилізують ртутні лампи.
Для мене ця справа — це можливість відкривати нові грані в собі.
Тому що я помітила, що за цей період,
який я працюю в організації,
дуже змінюється моє ставлення до людей,
моє ставлення, взагалі, до деяких речей.
І, на даний момент, мені це більше подобається.
Я не буду приховувати, що я роблю
це для себе, а не для когось.
Тому що якби я робила це для когось,
я б не змогла це робити так багато часу.
Я б вигоріла за якийсь період.
Я дуже намагаюся дотримуватися ще також того,
що всі продукти мають бути локальними.
Я купую те, що вирощене, тут, або поблизу
тієї місцевості, в якій я живу-знаходжуся.
Я саджаю дерева.
Я їжджу іноді на велосипеді, хоча іноді
доводиться їздити, звичайно, машиною.
Але власне...
Екоторбочки, пляшечки, ніякого поліетилену.
Іноді ти несеш якісь фрукти-овочі в себе в футболці.
Останні три роки були такими найактивнішими.
В людей змінюється дуже свідомість.
Люди бачать, що вони відповідальні за це все,
і вони вмотивовані, щоб такі
ініціативи були впроваджені.
Людям реально не байдуже.
Нас підтримують.
І для нас це хороший стимул працювати і не зупинятися.
[Автор проєкту,
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Продюсерки,
Каріна Пілюгіна
Наталка Панченко]
[Режисер,
Микола Носок]
[Режисерка монтажу,
Марія Теребус]
[Оператори,
Павло Пашко,
Яна Покидько]
[Асистенти продюсерок,
Наталя Вишинська,
Анастасія Бондаренко,
Максим Ситніков]
[Асистенти продюсерок,
Лідія Буляк,
Юлія Безпечна,
Вікторія Кравчук]
[Інтерв'юер,
Максим Ситніков]
[Ukraїner,
Експедиція]